bueno vamos a cerrar estas estas
conferencias de fin con la mía y voy a
hablar un poco sobre investigación luego
innovación y emprendimiento vale lo que
podemos hacer los científicos yo soy
científico formado como científico y
vamos a comentar todos estos avances que
hemos hecho tanto en europa como aquí en
el perú bien el primero presenté esta
imagen esta imagen es de saleh una
película de psyllium elysium que el
objetivo de esta película es ver las
importancias o las innovaciones que nos
pueden dar
el espacio no se ha llevado el objetivo
de esta película era llevarlo a un
pacientes o enfermos al espacio y ver
como seguro nos vamos a ver
de esta película un poco fantasiosa que
es cierre algo no vamos donde está el
error vale entonces vamos a hacer una
poca historia
esta historia nace de madrid que dio de
lima a madrid cuando me voy a hacer una
estancia o unos estudios de posgrado
allá en españa todo esto gracias a mis
padres que me dieron la oportunidad de
poder viajar el apoyo y eso lo
recomiendo a cada uno de ustedes jóvenes
siempre los padres son nuestro apoyo
luego de ello pues ya en la embajada en
la embajada aquí sucedió un pequeño
problema el problema fue de que cuando
no estaba en la mesa cada 9 que se
pueden pueden ver en la imagen el joven
que me atendió me hizo tres preguntas se
hiciera hasta ahora siempre lo recuerdo
la primera pregunta fue a dónde va que a
qué parte de españa vas madrid segunda
pregunta qué vas a hacer en madrid
estudiar y la tercera pregunta clave
esta beca me pidiera la beca y yo le
dije no la tengo pero tengo 1300 dólares
en mi bolsillo y dame la oportunidad de
poder estudiar másters
te prometo que el 50 por ciento de mi
tiempo me dedica a estudiar y el otro
50% que trabajaré porque es complicado
vivir allá y en diciembre me otorgaron
la visa
ya en españa conocí a roberto marcó mi
mentor científico que me hallo a su
grupo para trabajar en temas espaciales
y en este grupo pues conocí en aquel
entonces eran casi más del 50% eran
estudiantes doctor antes y algunos
doctor antes ahora ya todos son doctores
y están distribuidos en todo el mundo y
justo pues yo en aquel entonces ya
entrando ya había terminado en la
maestría en biofísica en autónoma de
madrid y estaba a trabajar en oficina de
patentes y marcas entre trabajé con
roberto en el doctorado y mi vida
durante el primer año en el doctorado
fue estar sentado frente a un ordenador
haciendo corriendo programas simulando
cosas numéricas haciendo bioinformática
programas que duraban 12 45 días eran
unos programas muy fuertes pero luego ya
con el tiempo como vi
en los laboratorios y yo era el único
físico ahí trabajando y todos eran
bioquímicos biólogos médicos
biotecnólogos porque estábamos en la
facultad de medicina en la universidad
tonometría los a un hospital otros
hospitales y entonces yo decidí realizar
o meterme mejor dicho en el mundo de la
biología molecular deje a un lado
la física y la matemática porque el
escuchar a los chicos hablar de
clonación es extracción análisis
genético amplificación purificación de
proteínas entonces eso como me escuchado
me emocionaba y yo en el ordenador
entonces yo hablé con mi jefe y le dije
mira y hemos avanzado bastante en el
análisis numérico hemos hecho programas
hemos validado algunos programas
entonces decidí
fue una locura realmente fue una locura
meterme en la investigación en biología
molecular tanto así que en la actualidad
no tengo un laboratorio de física física
si no tengo un laboratorio de biología
molecular aquí en la uni mejor dicho en
el intel um y entonces ya con esto ya
entrando en el mundo de la biología
molecular
ya pude entender un poco más de qué se
trataba el experimento de la tesis
doctoral la tesis doctoral tenía bueno
en aquel entonces ya muchos años han
pasado análisis de presión genética de
pulpa de drosophila melanogaster
expuestas a mikko realidad y para poder
entender que lo que está pasando en el
espacio pues nosotros en aquel momento
queríamos saber cómo desarrolla o cómo y
cómo la microgravedad actúa sobre la
expresión de genes en tres o fila
melanogaster para eso utilizamos la
emisión
cervantes que salió desde kazajistán ok
y utilizamos larvas de primer estadío e
hicimos se hizo una parada en toulouse
en francia luego pasó a rusia y de rusia
pero el de rusia volaron hacia la
estación espacial internacional pero de
madrid
'rusia baikonur hubo un tratamiento en
frío vale de 14 grados y luego volaron
directamente a la estación espacial
internacional
en paralelo ok y se hizo un trabajo en
una máquina simulador en microgravedad
que había en la agencia espacial europea
donde realizamos estancias ahí los
resultados fueron un poco interesantes
en el sentido de que ya la nasa y la esa
en aquel entonces habían desarrollado
investigaciones que la mosca o mejor
dicho a otros o fila melanogaster no
tenía ninguna alteración fenotípica por
lo tanto lanzaron una hipótesis diciendo
de que si no tiene una alteración que no
típica por lo tanto no va a tener una
alteración genética no típica ok en los
genes no en la forma entonces y estos
resultados
ok ya nos dieron
y nos trajeron abajo la hipótesis que
realmente no iba a tener una relación
genotípica y todo lo contrario
pudimos observar y ahí se ve claramente
que cada punto estos no representan la
expresión genética que quiere decir
cuando nosotros comparamos los niveles
de expresión genética tanto en el
espacio como un simulador con todos los
genes de drosophila todos los genes que
en ese entonces ya se podían hacer en el
2005 hacer análisis de microarrays que
duraban dos horas podemos ver y observar
con todo el ruido ya se observaba una
correlación entonces de ahí vino la
tesis la tesis no dio estos resultados
obtuvimos 806 genes que respondían a la
mi gravedad luego el algoritmo nos dio
un grupo de genes con una frecuencia
determinada que procesaba el programa
esto estos resultados lo tuvimos después
de 45 días que el computador estaba
corriendo
en el clase de correlación que nosotros
desarrollamos observamos que habían seis
genes que participaban en los clusters
ok y esos y genes los vimos interesantes
y eso sí genesini bien cuando nosotros
quisimos validar el algoritmo que fue
otra locura más cuando cuando sobre todo
los programadores aquí cuando crearon
algoritmos lo comparan con otro
algoritmo comercial es una locura
comparar un algoritmo con un experimento
biológico porque los sistemas biológicos
son totalmente estocásticos ok entonces
decidimos realmente hacer un experimento
biológico para poder comparar o ver si
es que realmente lo que habíamos
detectado estaba en lo cierto o no
por lo tanto realizamos de nuevo el
experimento del año de 2010 y que lo que
observamos lo que observamos era
que el comportamiento de esos genes era
similar solamente de que había
y un solapamiento quiere decir que el
experimento de 2010 solamente lo
tratamos en microgravedad
recuerden que les había comentado que el
experimento que lo llevamos al espacio
tuvo un tratamiento previo en frío
después microgravedad entonces como el
objetivo era ver si es que realmente
responden a la microgravedad eso es lo
que hicimos microgravedad nada más
entonces teníamos dos experimentos
distintos que la primera discusión en la
que no se pueden comparar los
experimentos distintos proyectos dos
experimentos distintos nos estaban dando
una un valor y unas interesante bien en
la gráfica verde y miren la gráfica roja
eso quiere decir que esos esos genes
están respondiendo de manera similar a
dos estímulos distintos lo que quiere
decir
que estos genes posiblemente tendrían
factores de regulación similares y eso
fue la siguiente tarea que nosotros
hicimos buscar del punto de vista de
informático los factores que lo regulan
a estos genes y que lo que pasó lo que
pasó que estos grupos de genes tenían
los mismos factores de regulación ok y
es por eso desde tu de vista
bioinformática y es por eso que los este
grupo de genes responde de manera
similar ok a dos estímulos distintos
entonces la siguiente tarea que se
reinició se realizó ya aqui en el peru
fue con mis alumnos de biología
computacional de la escuela de ciencias
aquí en la uni donde la tarea que les
comenté a ellos y es esta la tarea que
les comenté a ellos era que ingresen a
la base de datos de terceros
efe srz para buscar los reguladores
comunes o mejor dicho para buscar todos
los reguladores de esta base de datos
que están publicadas todas ser más de
300 genes que que son ya publicados como
reguladores en drosophila y que todos
los reguladores que todos son los
reguladores los busquen en los genes que
había detectado en la tesis doctoral y
que lo que pareció que ninguno de sus
reguladores aparecieron de entre los 806
genes que habíamos detectado como
respuesta a la microgravedad eso quiere
decir que los reguladores no estaban
funcionando en la mi gravedad por lo
tanto y aquí voy a la otra a la anterior
por lo tanto lanzamos a estos genes como
si fuesen genes sensores y aquí utilizo
yo la matemática del álgebra lineal
elegido lineal
lineal cuando nosotros lo utilizamos
para poder analizar un conjunto de
variables como si fuesen sensores tienen
que cumplir tres características la
primera es que tienen que tener una
relación
una relación temporal y que sean
linealmente independientes como lo llevo
esto la biología primero en la relación
espacial porque tienen que expresarse en
el mismo tejido perfecto estos genes son
genes musculares y eso lo están viendo
en la primera imagen segundo que tienen
que tener una relación temporal tiempo
quiere decir que los genes se expresan
en el mismo tiempo por lo tanto eso se
está observando y lo otro que son
linealmente independientes y es la
última gráfica que se observa y luego
hicimos una relación matemática ok
donde pudimos observar que realmente lo
que estaba pasando en estación espacial
internacional podría pasar en ese
simulador que nosotros tuvimos tuvimos
ahora concluimos que realmente la
microgravedad
está actuando está actuando sobre los
niveles de expresión genética bueno como
esto lo llevamos en aquel entonces lo
queríamos de la manera de cómo poder
relacionar con ondas gravitacionales y
esto es lo que hay en observatorio y
ligó en estos sonidos que utilizan estos
sensores láser para dictar
gravitacionales
donde hay pequeñas perturbaciones ok que
me den amstrong pero si nosotros podemos
utilizar la biología molecular también
para poder medir ellos por qué porque
nosotros podemos detectar pequeñas
pequeños núcleos claro que a una
distancia de 10 es al menos 9 metros con
respecto a las constantes
gravitacionales que sentí esas 10 al
menos 10 cosas podemos tener por ahí
relacionada relacionar los dos por lo
tanto eso es lo que vemos nosotros
desarrollado desarrollamos luego con
unos físicos teóricos que encontramos
utilizando la teoría de relatividad ok
vimos que había un coeficiente que se
permanece en este conjunto de gente que
los estuvimos investigando y lanzamos
este conjunto de genes como posibles
sensores a la microgravedad acá hicimos
como tuve la mi gravedad en un sistema
proteico por ejemplo que lo enrolle y
luego se enrolla y con esto nos lanzamos
a pensar que lo que está haciendo en la
nasa en la actualidad la nasa está
utilizando las investigaciones en
microgravedad
para poder hacer frente al cáncer
nuestros genes cuando los buscamos en
humanos regulan a tumores de epiteliales
angulares para poder hacer esta
investigación que hicimos comparar en
humanos igualitos si son genes base y
eso es lo que nosotros en la base de
datos stirling lo ubicamos también tan
igual lo relacionamos con una proteína
p53 es un reguladora tumoración y luego
de eso vimos en base de datos que estos
genes realmente ya están considerados en
forma independiente en forma
independiente como genes que regulan la
tumoración luego de eso hicimos un
estudio multidiversidad estos genes que
realmente los podemos utilizar como
genes sensores y este trabajo lo hemos
hecho gracias al apoyo que tenemos con
los investigadores con salud ya con esto
hicimos nosotros el siguiente paso que
hicimos es construir nuestro biochip
utilizando la realidad
nosotros hemos desarrollado nuestro
propio vídeo chip hemos comprado los
electrodos de oro y movilizamos hemos
desarrollado nuestra propia sonda son
ratio larga que automáticamente se une
al oro ok
luego la amplificamos y lo vemos de
ordenador los primeros resultados que
hemos obtenido es un resultado de
multimedia cíclica que ahí no se observa
casi nada no hay ninguna variación
pero luego hicimos estudios debe en
relación a perimétrica ok y podemos y
encontrar una variación de tal manera
que ahí ya podíamos nosotros formar
nuestro circuito eléctrico y ver cómo
están respondiendo en la resistencia
quiere decir cuando hay hibridación
aumenta la resistencia y cuando no hay
hibridación no aumenta la resistencia y
eso es lo que nos está dando nuestra
nuestro resultado ya con esto nosotros
construimos nuestro propio vídeo chip
maiden in perú
va a ser utilizado con pacientes de
oncosalud que lo tienen ahí y lo hemos
desarrollado aquí con científicos
peruanos ya con esto ya voy a terminar y
ya me regreso a perú de un viaje de
madrid a lima ya no podía un poco dormir
y comenzar a diseñar la máquina en
microgravedad
ok esta gama tiene mejorada como lo ven
no podía dormir la diseñé y luego ya en
lima tuvimos este primer diseño esta
primera construcción que digo y el eje
principal lo tienen en la parte central
y lo que hicimos nosotros cambiarlo
porque estaba en la misma dirección no
tenía la tierra el eje de la tierra y
por lo tanto lo colocamos al costado ya
en lima construimos
mejoramos el equipo con proyectos de
innovar ok ahí está
luego como sabíamos que inhibían a las
células tumorales hicimos un horno
ahí está la máquina en mi gravedad con
un arma dentro y nosotros colocamos
células tumorales ahí y vemos como las
células mueren por apoptosis luego de
esto ya con unos socios en españa y
nosotros construimos ya una máquina o
esto es una locura ya porque esta
máquina que hay en españa que nos lo
hemos desarrollado lo hemos construido
estamos utilizando bueno se quiere
utilizar para pacientes y esta máquina
tiene cuatro metros cuatro metros de
altura por 16 metros de área entonces el
paciente va a estar en medio y va a
comenzar a laburar os prometo que esta
máquina vendrá al perú para ser aplicada
terminó igual que en españa
y ya con esto me quedan solamente las
transparencias nos preguntamos oye pero
hasta ahora no nos indica que lo que
hace la micro edad cómo se hace la micro
o sea la aventura de la lenta y tu
máquina entonces para eso he puesto tres
imágenes y lo pueden hacer sencillamente
en su caso ok
imagínense que tú tienen ustedes tienen
una fresa y leche condensada en la
estrella coloquen la fresa dentro de la
leche condensada en este luego retiren y
que lo que van a observar lo que van a
observar es que la leche condensada en
estrella se precipita hacia la tierra ok
por efectos de la gravedad hagan el
mismo experimento ingrese en la máquina
que yo ingresé a la fresa dentro la
leche condensada de estrella y luego
reciben pero comiencen a mover en todas
las direcciones muy lentamente y que lo
que observan lo que observa es que la
leche condensada en estrés no cae hacia
la tierra no es jalado ok entonces eso
es lo que está ocurriendo en nuestra
máquina en microgravedad
los movimientos aleatorios en todas las
direcciones hace que todo lo que se
encuentra ahí se genere en un principio
de microgravedad por lo tanto y ahora
podemos entender realmente lo que el
espacio nos está dando y lo que nos está
dando el espacio es que realmente
podemos nosotros muy pronto tener
posiblemente un hospital oncológico en
el espacio y poder llevar pacientes allá
y ver la manera de cómo aseguran por lo
tanto esta película al menos algo de
ciencia ficción tenía con esto gracias
[Aplausos]